well hard to believe local schools are
back in session just two weeks from
today
but will the students be ready bianca
holman is live with details on a big
back to school event getting underway
this morning good morning bianca tell us
more about it
hey good morning sheri so we're here at
the paradise recreation center and later
on this morning starting at nine
and lasting until noon they're going to
be passing out backpacks and school
supplies
families can get eye exams and also
information about the upcoming school
year
and as we talk about the ups coming
school year we were able to
obtain information about the last
semester the last
school year that students just finished
up and it shows that the copin 19
pandemic and distance learning
had a negative effect on student grades
nearly 51 percent of middle school
students received at least one
f grade that's more than double the
previous year
it was 40 percent for high schoolers and
31 for elementary
it is a real issue
that students have lost out on a lot of
of learning in the last year and a half
missing one of those foundational
concepts
really then kind of created a domino
effect for some of our students
and we've got an in-depth look at all
that information on our website at
eightnewsnow.com and as far as the event
happening here at the paradise
recreation center
again it starts at nine wraps at noon
backpacks eye exam supplies all the
information you need to know
to get off to the right start for the
upcoming school year
and again here at the recreation center
and also
the parent you must have your child
children you got to be with a parent or
guardian reporting live from near
eastern and
tropicana bianca holman 8 news now